with up-to-the-minute results all night
long
eight news now your local election
headquarters
welcome to election day 2020.
and good evening to you thanks for
joining us on eightnewsnow.com or maybe
you're watching on facebook and don't
forget our newscast starts in about a
half hour on channel 8 at 11.
all right so we have got some early
numbers here for you throughout
the state taking a look at the big race
tonight between joe biden and donald
trump
52 for joe biden 46 for
president trump and these numbers do
include clark county we're now looking
at the highly contested
congressional district three for the u.s
house of reps
we see susie lee with 50 percent five
points up on
big dan rodimer with 45 percent who is
challenging the incumbent this is
district four
district four also the incumbent here
the democrat stephen horsford
53 percent over his challenger jim
marchant at 45
percent and then i think next we're
going to have the race the
high profile race for the nevada justice
for the supreme court
douglas herndon with a strong lead this
early in the evening with the
46 percent over ozzie fumo at 37 percent
we're now going to take a look at county
commission there's the numbers coming in
for district c
couldn't be much closer ross miller
stavros
anthony both at 50 percent separated
only by hundreds
of votes and now it's about time for the
republican watch party
yeah that's happening tonight at the
south point they're getting their
results in tonight both locally and
across the country joe moeller is at
their watch party and joins us now with
more
joe
good evening guys it's been a little bit
of a different sort of watch party
because the pandemic is happening so
they've kind of limited the amount of
people able to come in here
the south point hotel and casino but a
lot of people have been excited and
eager to see how this night is going to
pan out joining right now is kaya
kravikis a trump supporter here watching
this all unfold
what is going through your mind as you
sit and you watch these monitors
so much anxiety i'm nervous
i woke up really early this morning
nervous
hoping the president does well his
energy is really great the rallies look
awesome
and just wanting to see that result turn
out in the election tonight
so we've been watching state by state
unfold but there's still a lot of states
that have not been called yet are you
eager to find out what's going to happen
next
including our own kind of concerned
about
why it's taking so long like why states
may be more on the east coast or
not falling through like on time like
they should be
i mean you know we don't push back new
year's eve
so i kind of wonder like if people were
to vote why they wouldn't have had it
done by now
and kind of what's going on so it's a
little bit nerve-racking but
excited to be here it's a really great
energy in this crowd tonight all right
thank you so much for joining us and
talking to us we do appreciate it but
you can see you'll still see there is
some people here this watch party is
going to wrap up here
in about a half an hour's time but this
is a lot different than we've seen in
the past they did limit the seating here
but people are very eager to see what
exactly is going to happen tonight
reporting live here at the south point
joe mullen
okay joe thank you for that report at
the republican watch party we want to
take a look at some of the
statewide ballot questions kirsten joyce
has stayed up with us tonight joins us
now live with those updates
thank you brian and denise let's take a
look at this question one
would it is a yes oh to know 50 50 very
close there folks nevada legislature
more control over the state's college
and university system separated only
by a mere 13 000 votes at 50 50.
question
2 would essentially take the language
out that says marriage is between a man
and a woman
yes at 63 percent to know at 37.
question 3 makes it so the state board
of pardons meets more often four times a
year to two that's a 61 percent yes 39
no question 4 enshrines our voting bill
of rights into the constitution that's a
63 percent for yes
37 for now and question 6 puts
the 50 by 30 renewable energy standard
into our state constitution 58 percent
of the votes with yes
to 42 percent no brian and denise
kirsten thank you the democrats are all
gathered at springs preserve to
cheer on their candidates and really to
monitor some really close
tight races yeah erko mana is out
speaking to party leaders earlier
tonight and orco i understand
it's a different calmer type of party
there this evening
well denise and bryant that's right i
wouldn't even really call it a party and
brian you mentioned us
you know hanging out with those
democratic leaders here it's more of a
setup shop here because there is no
official watch party it's just the media
really talking to those
uh state party leaders like i mentioned
earlier tonight
we're trying to get some reaction from
the congressional
candidates as well as the state party
here but as you can see there's not much
going on so we are
trying to get some reaction again
getting those numbers trickling in from
clark county right now
looks like joe biden is about 10 points
ahead of donald trump
using those numbers we're getting from
clark county a close race with susie lee
as well the incumbent democrat
and it really is a different kind of
party here the reason the state party
decided to do it this way without
a crowd of supporters is because of the
coronavirus pandemic
but again we are awaiting all the
official results joe biden took the
stage
not too long ago saying we will not rest
until this
all the votes are counted that includes
all the votes here in nevada
so again we are trying to get some more
reaction from
our democrats here locally to get some
sense of where they're at i know they
really hoped that they would
see a larger blow out here they talked a
lot about a blue wave in the past couple
of weeks
leading up to election night where they
really ramped up their canvassing and
voter mobilization efforts
again we are seeing slight leads right
now in those close races from the
democrats but
again it does seem pretty tight and we
are waiting to get some more reaction
from those
local democrats here in nevada so
hopefully we'll get some of that soon
but
for now reporting live orco mana 8 news
now
okay thank you so we went through some
of the ballot initiatives just a moment
ago now let's get an update on some of
the school board races
uh let's check in with kirsten yes
denise there are four open seats these
are non-partisan
so you won't see a party attached to
them let's see where we're at for
district a we have leo guzman at 53
percent to liberty levitt at 47
they are replacing uh they would be
replacing the trustee deanna wright
and um that has lisa guzman leading that
district b we have katie williams at 61
to jeff profit at 39 percent both of the
women in the running for district c
products of the community they hope to
oversee and evelyn garcia morales at 52
percent
come here to compared to tamika at 48
percent
and in district e which is the summerlin
area as well mount charleston in indian
springs for schooling
we have lola brooks that is who is
currently holding the seat as well she's
the only incoming among all four school
board races
and she's got 57 percent of the vote
compared to alexis salt
at 43 percent denise and brian
kirsten thank you so much we're going to
take a look now at some legislature
races
we'll have those pop up on your screen
in just a second first this is state
senate district five you see the numbers
coming in with christy watson
with a one point lead close margin over
carrie ann buck 49 percent to 48.
then for district six uh nicole jeanette
cannizzaro this is the one that
a lot of people have been talking about
we saw a lot of ads for this one
this is neck and neck between nicole
canozzaro and
april becker fifty percent and fifty
percent
next up we have state senate district
fifteen
heidi sievers gancert is at 51 percent
also
a relatively close rate two points over
wendy giorgo jackins and that is again
51 to 49 percent
for state senate district 15. all right
some of the assembly races now for
district two between heidi kasim at 53
percent
and radica canal at 45 percent
moving forward with the last race we'll
be looking at state assembly district
four
richard mcarthur on the left 52 percent
a four-point margin separating him from
connie monk who is the democrat in this
race 52
to 48 percent for macarthur and i think
brian we've got one more we're going to
take a look at here
this one also fairly close for district
seat this is for 37
andrew andy matthews at 51 percent
and shea bacchus at 49 lots of races to
look at tonight but now we're starting
to get a clearer picture
as more numbers are coming in statewide
time right now is 10 42 you're watching
that eight newsnow.com or
on facebook make sure you join us in 18
minutes
on channel eight eight news now for our
11 p.m newscast where we look at what is
really a close presidential race
also the congressional races full
coverage on national and local elections
in 17 minutes thanks for watching we'll
see you then